playing the winner by knock on door
andhe Rousey is having a great week she
not only defeated a trash-talking
opponent in 34 seconds but we also got
news that she'll be starring in her own
biopic so who is this woman who's worthy
of starring in the movie about her own
life
I'm drew Coolidge we're gonna find out
who Ronda Rousey really is this is
hashtag news Ronda Rousey is the UFC
Women's Champion that means she fights
with her hands her feet her arms legs -
like the bicep only her whole body yeah
that's what I'm saying she wrote an
autobiography called my fight your fight
and now they're making that book into a
movie and before you ask yes her life is
worth making a movie about here's why
first of all she's a great fighter no
seriously she beat a previous opponent
less than 15 seconds the entire thing
fit on Instagram and the latest one was
like 34 seconds and that opponent was a
serious trash talker she was getting in
her face the way in saying things like
don't cry don't cry Ronda she was like a
rock when she knocked her down 34
seconds later of course she's gonna make
a call back I turned around to her after
I knocked her out and I said don't cry
right your face I love her if she keeps
this thing going her next fight will be
able to fit on vine I think the only way
to last longer with her in the Octagon
is to literally run away so the only
person who has a chance I was Lolo Jones
so here's a quick list of her
accomplishment Ronda is undefeated in
mixed martial arts going 12 and oh she's
the first and current UFC women's
bantamweight champion and she's the
first American woman to get an Olympic
medal in judo
now all great athletes get their own
biopic but there's not a lot of
actresses available in the ability to
murder you with their feet casting type
so she's gonna play herself in her own
biopic only the truly great have started
their own biopic Babe Ruth Muhammad Ali
Jackie Robinson and Eminem if you count
eight mile which I do rapping is a sport
I get sweaty when I do it but is she
ready to start her own movie I think so
she's been acting a lot recently she was
in Expendables three Furious 7 the
entourage movie where she finally beats
up turtle thank you Ronda is she a great
actress
couldn't last 30 seconds to me if your
life depended on she would beat me up if
I said otherwise so yes she's great
give her an Oscar before she started
filming so what would this biopic be
about where does a woman this kick-ass
come from she comes from a line of
badass women mom was the first u.s.
citizen
that's male or female to win a world
judo championship she's had her own
hardships that she's had to deal with
she didn't even start speaking until she
was four years old and her father
committed suicide when Rhonda was just
eight years old when she was asked if
these things made her stronger she said
I believe going through the worst things
possible makes everything less than that
seem much less intimidating because I've
already been through the worst and
survived it's pretty inspiring
she's even tried picking fights with a
few guys she has a feud with boxer Floyd
Mayweather known for domestically
abusing women when Rousey won best
fighter at the 2015 SP Awards she said I
wonder how Floyd feels being beat by a
woman for once when asked if she'd ever
fight him she said I don't think me and
him would ever fight unless we ended up
dating and what's more she's a positive
influence she's inspiring a whole
generation of girls to accept their
bodies as they are and be as tough as
they want to be I have this one term for
the kind of woman that my mother raised
me to not be and I call it a do-nothing
[ __ ] that's why I think it's hilarious
if people like say that my body looks
masculine or something like that I'm
just like just because my body was
developed for a purpose other than
millionaires doesn't mean it's masculine
I think it's definitely badass because
there's not a single muscle on my body
that isn't for a purpose because I'm not
a do-nothing [ __ ] Rhonda is inspiring
she's not only the best fighter out
there she's also beautiful smart witty
lot of photographs of you in here quite
quite nude my hand wraps on if you put
your hand raps on she's finally a
positive female role model someone who
accepts herself as she really is and is
making a powerful statement about women
just go out do what you want to do be
who you want to be look like you look
it's all fine and it's all great that's
inspiring so what do you guys think of
Rhonda let us know in the comments if I
were you I wouldn't piss her off just
keep that in mind she's got a big social
media team that just reads YouTube
comments
she can go punch people door-to-door I
don't think that's true but I really
hope it is so subscribe to NMR if you
want more videos about fighting whether
it's real people or fictional people on
the big screen we cover it all
I'm drew Coolidge and Rhonda you've
inspired me to quit being a DnB a
do-nothing [ __ ] douchey newborn baby
you're not a baby drew right